por sus hijos y por todos fue el lema de
vida debe de bonafini desde que en 1977
La dictadura Argentina desapareciera a
dos de sus hijos lideró desde entonces
la asociación de Madres de Plaza de Mayo
se manifestaban todos los jueves con un
emblemático pañuelo blanco y el
propósito de encontrar a sus hijos
de nuestro corazón La dictadura
Argentina desapareció a más de 30.000
personas la mayoría de izquierda entre
1976 y 1983 Eve de bonafini pasó de ama
de casa a un activista en defensa por
los derechos humanos y no tuvo reparos
en enfrentarse a quien fuera siendo
arrestada En diversas ocasiones yo digo
cuando me llevaron mis hijos me
crecieron leones dentro
bonafini tuvo un gran compromiso
político ante imperialista y cercano a
figuras como Hugo Chávez Evo Morales y
la actual vicepresidenta Argentina
Cristina Fernández de kirchner quien
lamentó su muerte en Twitter
queridísima Eve madre de Plaza de Mayo
símbolo mundial de lucha por los
Derechos Humanos orgullo de la Argentina
Dios te llamó el día de la soberanía
nacional no debe ser casualidad
simplemente Gracias y hasta siempre
tras la caída de la dictadura de Jorge
Videla continuó reivindicando el
enjuiciamiento de los responsables y
trabajó en la recuperación de la
identidad de más de 100 bebés robados
por la dictadura las madres de mayo se
dividieron en dos asociaciones su
organización logró construir casas para
familias empobrecidas fundó una
universidad e impulsó una radio una
imprenta y una web
como persona soy mucho mejor persona
entendí que era la solidaridad la
revolución el amor el amor al otro y eso
lo entendí porque me quedaba muy grabada
las palabras de mis hijos
93 años de lucha para Eve quien desde el
dolor de sus entrañas puso su grano de
arena para conseguir un mundo mejor